anyone here old enough to remember this
this is turbo pass it's actually Topher
scale - whoa but turbo pascal bueno
turns 35 years old today and that was
the first product that I I worked on
here's a later screen grab of turbo
Pascal five-o Delphi that Christoph
mentioned I'm sure some of you would
probably know c-sharp that I that I also
worked on but but today I'm here to talk
about typescript and as you can tell I
obviously have a fascination with
programming languages and development
environments and in particular the
symbiosis between the two and and
typescript is no exception
the story of typescript starts about
eight years ago late 2010 early 2011 and
at that time there were sort of this
perfect storm happening on the web we
were moving from a world that was very
homogeneous sort of dominated by Windows
desktops to a very heterogeneous world
of devices in all sorts of different
form factors and operating systems and
so cross-platform was really becoming
super important and at the same time
also JavaScript VMs were getting way way
better I mean already and at that time
we were at least seeing a 10x
improvement from the great work that
Google did with v8 and and Mozilla and
and even Microsoft where chakra engine
and and it was sorta on this steady
upward march of better and better
performance and Egmore script five had
been ratified and html5 was on the on
the verge and so it was becoming not
just necessary but also possible to
write real-world apps in in the browser
and certainly history has borne this out
if you look at you know shortly after we
started with with with with typescript
javascript jumped into the number one
spot of most popular programming
languages and traded with Java and has
pretty much stayed there ever since
so it's with with this backdrop that in
2010 this group of people came came to
the developer group and asked whether we
would consider productizing a project
called script sharp now at the time I
was working on the c-sharp programming
language and script sharp was this tool
that allows you to cross compile C sharp
to JavaScript in a sense just treating
JavaScript as an il right and I was like
well why why would you why would you
want to do that and and this this this
tool was being used internally by the
outlook.com team but Google had a
similar toolkit called GWT that they
were using for a bunch of their
properties and and so I got curious
about what what the reason was and and
it turned out you know that there are
there are a couple of reasons we all
know that javascript has has issues and
at the time it had way more issues than
it does now it didn't have classes it
didn't have modules and it didn't have a
type system that allows you to describe
and document your code which is super
helpful when you're working in big teams
and when you want to statically check
your program before you deploy it and
also a lot of the tools at the time for
JavaScript development kind of looked
like this you know there was just
nothing no help no colorization no
statement completion no code navigation
and again part of the reason was that
there is no type system in the language
that can inform these tools and you need
all of that information or build great
tools so that was sort of a Genesis
moment for us this is where we go well
gosh you know how we're never going to
be best to breathe by try getting
JavaScript from c-sharp or some other
language what if we instead could work
on fixing the problems that that that
we're seeing here like you know adding
adding a type system that's optional
adding classes modules and so forth and
that really sort of was the genesis of
of typescript so typescript starts with
JavaScript as I'm sure a lot of you know
- which we then add a static type system
plus missing features or at least they
were at the time like classes and
modules and then on top of that we build
great tooling but then when you compile
your code you just left again with plain
old JavaScript so there's really no
notion of-of any of this having existed
other than at at development time so
that's in a nutshell typescript we
shipped it in six years ago what's the
first public release and here are sort
of devalues the value system that we
that we live by we are fully open source
and open development we are on github
the team is there every day we try to
closely track the echo script standard
so we don't see it as our job to add new
features in the core language but rather
we want to innovate in the type system
that's sort of our purview but that is a
development time only thing we strive to
build best to be tooling and continually
lower the barrier to entry and listen to
our our community this is the group of
people that build the product most of
them in Redmond and what I wanted to do
now is try to dive in a little bit and
talk a little bit about the type system
because that's sort of like the crown
jewels of Thomas of typescript that's
what makes it different our type system
has a whole bunch of interesting
attributes that I've never seen in in
other type systems I've listed all of
them here but rather than breed them to
you here I'm gonna try to go through a
series of illustrations of what what
this means and so starting with this
notion that types are erasable here's a
piece of typescript that the way we
declare a person type and then we
annotate our parameter called person on
greeting and we annotate our user
variable with that type and once we do
that then our tool now I IDE knows
what's going on and can give us
statement completion that knows what the
properties of that type are it can check
that you're not accessing other
properties and so forth but when you
compile
all of that stuff just evaporates so so
there is actually no notion of types
ever having existed in the in the final
code and this is what you actually end
up running and it's just plain old
JavaScript in fact you could feed this
to the typescript compiler because
typescript is a superset so this is just
this is just typescript with no type
annotations and if you do then we can
actually infer types in a lot of cases
so so inference is super important to us
and and in a lot of cases you really
don't have to write type annotations
although if you do feed this program for
for the person parameter on greeting we
just infer to type any which means it
could be anything
and now you might go well gosh listen
you're you're you could infer the type
of user and you're calling greeting with
you so couldn't you infer what the type
of person is from that then some type
systems do that that's like non-local
type different type inference where
you're inferring from calls but the
problem is imagine that that call sat
very far away in a different module and
all of a sudden started passing some
different parameters and then all of a
sudden over here we would in front we
would infer different types for the
parameter that's sort of like this
spooky action at a distance which in
Haskell and ml can sometimes be very odd
and we strive to not do that so so any
inference we do we keep it local our
type system is structural here's an
example again if you look at the the
type annotation on person in the first
function there you see that we haven't
even given it a name we've just said
it's something that has a name property
and then it doesn't really matter how
you get that name property you could get
it by being an instance of a class that
has it or you could write an object
literal or a number of other ways what
matters here is the structure just the
fact that you have that property this is
distinctly different from languages like
say c-sharp or a Java where you would
have to declare an interface called
thing with name and then you would have
to have your person class implement that
interface and only if it
that interface can you actually pass it
around so interoperability in those
languages is much much harder there's
much more friction where JavaScript
actually is duck typed right and and
really our static our structured type
system is a structural type system is
really just a static formalization of
duck typing and that is how JavaScript
works we have a generic type system
which means you can declare things like
this this here which is a strongly type
node in a tree where P is the type of
the parent pointer and because we're
structural if you have two types that
are identical in structure they need to
be compatible with each other so let's
say I have a node of something at an
item of something and I try to assign
one to the other in a nominal type
system that would be an error because it
is not the same type but in a structural
type system it should be okay which
means we're gonna say node of knowledge
across is note of knowledgeable - item
of null then we look at a structure well
yes they both have a data property yes
they have a parent property which is
gonna be of type null and then they have
children which is of type node of node
of null now let's compare those off we
go compare yes yes yes now note of node
of node of null node of node of node of
node of null and it's Turtles all the
way down this is very hard to implement
the nominal type systems are a lot
simpler but in structural type systems
you are staring into the recursive abyss
all the time and you need to find ways
to not go off and do infinite amounts of
work and so we have something that we
affectionately called a turtle cut off
in the compiler where where we say after
five turtles maybe we should look at the
rest of the types and if all adapt works
out then we're just going to say it's
okay with a high degree of certainty
because it is not possible to really
truly tell
union types are another thing that we
have here here the ability to annotate a
parameter with being either string or
number or boolean and then when you
couple that with control flow analysis
then wonderful things come come out of
it here for example we can infer that
the type of X inside that if statement
is just string because what the guard
that went before it we can narrow the
Union type down to to just string and
then following the assignment it becomes
a number and then that means at the
bottom we have number or boolean now
that's super super handy when it comes
to checking for null and undefined
because in strict mode and typescript
null and undefined are separate types
and so if you guard with X equal to null
and return then we know through our
control flow analyzer that X is not null
in the rest of the function because it's
been guarded a lot of people say I don't
like typescript is all about programming
it's all about OOP and you know we we
don't want
OOP we want functional programming well
it turns out that we are actually really
great at a bunch of functional paradigms
here for example is what we call a
discriminated Union type that has a kind
property and it can be one of three
different kinds and then in the area
function when you are in each of the
different cases we can narrow down to
the appropriate case and only make those
properties accessible and we can also
know that you've handled all the cases
which means that the bottom of the
switch statement is unreachable and
therefore the in the implied undefined
that the function would return otherwise
isn't actually there and therefore the
inferred return type is number not
number or undefined and so there's a
whole bunch of intelligent stuff that
happens here but this is just pure old
JavaScript but when you when you squint
this is just like an algebraic data type
in one of the functional programming
languages like Haskell and ml and a lot
of the same techniques like exhaustive
nice check in and whatever become
possible with with with typescript
indeed javascript is this interesting
language where
you know you can do things that don't
even exist in other programming
languages like have string Li typed
api's where you pass property names as
strings and through some of the type
system operators that we have like Kiev
and index access types the T sub K there
we can actually strongly type these
patterns and give you an error on the
last line here because we know that the
string literal you're passing in is
supposed to be a property name in the
object that you're passing in in fact we
have a bunch of esoteric types that that
that we've dreamt up just to match
Tavia Java JavaScript capabilities like
lookup and map types and and and the
latest one is conditional types in fact
someone actually proved that our type
system is touring complete you can do
computation in the type system if you
guys want to see something crazy go look
at that particular issue it's still up
on on github another thing that we have
is is strict mode it's sort of a dilemma
for us because when we evolved the type
checker we are in a sense breaking your
build every time we release because we
get better at checking and we might find
new errors that we didn't find before
and therefore your build is broken now
in order to handle that we allow you to
to opt into features individually or you
can opt into strict mode in which case
you're saying yes I want maximum type
checking at all time and that just
enables a whole family of stricter
checks another thing I wanted to talk
about that special about typescript is
this notion of using the compiler as a
as a service
compilers traditionally with these
things where you know in comes input
files and out ghost output files and
magic happens in the middle that only
the compiler writers understand but but
in reality today
compilers need to be opened up and
become api's because that is what
enables all of these wonderful features
that we expect to have in our IDE s and
indeed the typescript compiler has an
entire API on it where you can use the
parser the type checker and so
fourth and embedded in your own tools
and tools indeed do that like TS lint
and web pack and all sorts of other
other tools also we work really hard to
make it easy to embed in different
editors so visual studio code for
example sublime text vim Emacs all have
plugins that allow you to use typescript
in there and in order to make them as
easy as possible we actually have a
thing called typescript server that runs
as a separate process that the editor
extension can talk to through a JSON
protocol and then all the magic happens
over in that server and the protocol
just tells the server what editing app
actions happen so another thing that we
need to really focus on is performance
there's sort of this magic number for
IDE s 250 milliseconds if it takes
longer than that when you press dot then
users get irritated so that's a hard
problem to solve if you have a hundred
thousand line program and the user is
typing a president's dot and now in 250
milliseconds you have to somehow figure
out what comes here and obviously you
can't compile all hundred thousand lines
and and do that here's an example of the
responsiveness you see when I type dot
for on program here this is a hundred
thousand line program this is the
typescript compiler and language service
itself and you see how how we are
probably sub hundred milliseconds in in
response here even though technically
you could reference anything from that
100,000 line program right there now the
way we do that is when we're running
this typescript server when the editor
extension talks to it let's say it tells
it that I've loaded a file then we go
parse that file into a syntax tree then
we analyze that syntax tree to see what
this file references through imports for
example and then we can build a full
closure of everything that we need to
know and hold on to it in memory because
we're sitting as a service out there now
let's say the user presses dot
we need to know something about what's
in scope here then we need to build
simple tables for each of these guys
then we can build a global simple table
and now we can start to answer the
question but the minute we answer the
question the user actually as a result
of pressing dot modifies a file and now
we made our assumptions invalid and a
program by the way is also broken
because there's an error because he
hasn't actually typed what comes after
so now we have modified a program and
it's broken yet in 250 milliseconds we
need to figure out what comes next now
what we do know though is that we can
clear out the information just for that
file and then we can incrementally
recompute it and reconstitute it and
then answer the question and even in the
process of incrementally building we can
use some of the old data structures that
we have parts of the syntax trees that
weren't modified but you'll note that if
we had a hundred files here 99 of them
did not get modified and so we saved
ourselves a bunch of time and so there's
a whole bunch of techniques that you
have to do when you build compilers this
way and these are techniques that you're
not really taught in school this is this
is something that you learn by doing but
you can you can see it all in our github
repo it's an interesting piece of code
in terms of community there's this
fantastic website our github site out
there called definitely type where the
community is collecting type information
for JavaScript programming on the web it
just this year moved into the top 10
most active repositories on github so
it's up there like along with Linux and
react and like some really big players
and it goes to show how much activity
there is here and basically this is
turned into a treasure trove of
information because it really documents
in a uniform manner how all of the
frameworks on the web work and I'll show
you an example of how we can put that to
to good use we also try to really work
with all the other tools that are out
there in in Babel the latest version of
Babel now supports typescript and
typescript boy you could always use it
just as a type checker and so that means
now that react is within reach you know
for
for a lot of users they can use
typescript and babble that's becoming
very popular and we see ourselves sort
of ask this Switzerland of frameworks we
don't really like try to try to cater to
one particular framework we work with
the domain engineering groups of all of
these different frameworks and make sure
that we have all the right features
handled for them so you might say but I
don't like types it's like they get in
my way you know I I like you know I like
parachuting I like bungee jumping I just
want to like write myself some code you
know and I I actually serious I can
understand that there are there are
scenarios where it's just maybe not
worth it for you but but it turns out
that we can actually still deliver a
bunch of value because typescript is a
superset of JavaScript which means
JavaScript it's a subset of typescript
which means we can actually use the
typescript language service to analyze
JavaScript it's just like JavaScript
with no annotations right and so here's
a little example of me starting a
completely blank project I have
installed lodash as a node module but
that's all I've done and now I start a
blank file and I just start typing this
is the in Visual Studio code import
underbar from and then C we get
statement completion on low - but now if
I say let x equals underbar dot then
notice statement completion this came
because we could auto provision from
definitely typed and graphed all the
type information from there and we could
actually now put that to good use and
show you what's possible too tight or
too right here even though you haven't
said any type annotations now if you if
you say go to definition you can see
that we actually go into the declaration
file for low - on that particular
identifier also you might have say J s
doc annotations in in your code and we
can actually scrape those and treat them
as type annotations right so here's a
function that just takes some s but now
when I say S dot you'll see that I get
statement completion because we scraped
the jst
a connotation that we know what the what
the properties are on string but if I
call it we don't give you error because
hey this is JavaScript I mean it's
possible but and likewise if you spelled
this wrong up there we also don't give
you an error however you can opt into
what we call TS check which is basically
go check it and if you're absolutely
sure there is an error then show us that
error and also in here you'll see that
now you can actually use refactorings to
go to the rename and and whatever and so
we can do a lot without type annotations
and you can get a lot of the benefits
from from typescript without actually
ever really using it which i think is
pretty cool ok final thing I wanted to
show is just a slide that made me a
graph that made me happy here recently
typescript has now moved into the
seventh spot of the top languages on
github and I'm of course a little bit
ambivalent about who we have to beat
next to move up but but nonetheless this
this this is great so this wouldn't have
happened without your support I know I
actually by show of hands how many of
you use typescript currently oh my god
that is that warms my heart I want to
give you a heartfelt thank you and I
also want to say that for those of you
who haven't yet used it give it a shot I
think it might actually make you more
productive s as programmers thank you
[Applause]